[Music]
Hey, I'm Will and with Noble Locksmith
and you're watching my YouTube channel,
Car Key Wizard. I'm an automotive
locksmith and while I definitely don't
know it all, I have learned some tricks
along the way that I hope will help you
while you're out in the field. One thing
you can do to help me out though would
be to subscribe to my channel. And if
you like my videos, leave a comment or
ask a question and I'll get back to you
as soon as I can. I make a lot of
videos, so if there's something you'd
like to learn more about or a video
you'd like to see on a car we're working
on, just let me know in the comments and
I'll put it up as soon as I can. Thanks,
and I hope you enjoy watching my videos.
[Music]
All right, we are on a 2015 Honda Pilot
Touring. We're doing a remote head key.
This is all keys lost. What I do with
basically all Hond's except the newer
ones where the remote programs in with
the key, I will um onboard the remote
first to make sure you have the right
one. There's only one option for this
one, but I did it anyway. I'll do it
again just to show you how. Um, you turn
the key on to ignition, hit one of the
buttons, back off, on button. You do
that three times, and then it's going to
cycle the locks. Hit a button on the
remote, turn it off, you're good to go.
One,
two,
3,
four. There goes the locks. One more to
take my remote back off. So, we know
this remote works. We can go ahead and
program the key.
Um, I do auto propad. Any any programmer
will do these. It's a pretty easy car. I
just use auto propad because it seems to
get in and read it a little bit quicker.
Do auto search. Ignition is already on.
That is the correct car. We're on a
blade key.
Switch is still on.
This is why I use auto propad. Um, alt
tell takes a pretty good bit longer to
get that pulled.
We're going to go to key.
All keys lost.
We're going to be putting one key in.
Turn ignition off.
Back on. And on the third one, it's
going to put the immobilizer light out
and we will be good.
Emoite is out. So, we are good to go.
Just got to get back out of programming.
Key registration complete. We're good to
go. We're going to turn it off to start
the car up.
[Music]
Car starts.
It's already locked.
Did I lose my remote?
That's funny. I must have taken it back
out. We'll throw it back in again. On.
Hit the button. Off. On.
Button. Off. On. Button. Off. On. Lock.
Cycle.
There's my key. Back off. And now we
have remote back. Like I said, I had
already done it and I guess doing it
that second time took it out. But that's
how you do that. We have working
buttons. Um the hatch on this car
doesn't work. Uh his buttons don't work
in the car, so the hatch is not going to
work. But we're good to go.